[Music]
thank you
J.R.R Tolkien is going to end his essay
on fairy stories by introducing a new
term to express a concept of reality
that he wants to Signal as being
absolutely Central to good fairy stories
and that is eukatastrophe and you know
you if you know anything about ancient
Greek means well or good catastrophe I
think we all know what that means and
he's going to contrast this against a
deuce catastrophe right so a catastrophe
we usually think of that as a negative
thing but in fact it could come in good
or bad well or ill variance right or we
could say modalities
so he's talking about consolation and he
will tell us in the end of this section
that the consolation of fairy tales has
another aspect in the imaginative
satisfaction of ancient or what he's
called earlier primordial desires
far more important he tells us is the
consolation of the happy ending now we
should pause here for a moment because
perhaps we become a bit jaded
particularly if we're fantasy fans or
speculative fiction fans Oh Happy
Endings that's for people who can't
handle reality and you know Grim dark
and all that kind of stuff he doesn't
mean a happy ending like some pollyanish
and then everything turned out okay in
the end kind of nonsense he means
something much deeper than that so he
says almost I would venture to assert
that all complete fairy fairy stories
must have it I would say that tragedy is
the true form of drama its highest
function but the opposite is true of
fairy story since we don't appear to
possess a word that expresses this
opposite I will call it you catastrophe
the U catastrophic tale is as he says
the true form of fairy tale and now
notice this its highest function so a
fairy tale has many many functions but
its highest function when we actually
look at it is this thing that up until
this point didn't have a name but we we
understood in a sense
so he goes on and he says
um a couple things about this the joy of
the happy ending or more correctly of
the good catastrophe the sudden joyous
turn for there is no true end to any
fairy tale there's joy which is one of
the things a fairy tales can produce
supremely well is not as he's going to
say essentially Escapist or to use
another word fugitive right it's not
about fleeing from things so what is it
about he says that in its fairy tale or
other world setting it is a sudden and
miraculous Grace never to be counted on
to recur so when we think about what
this term Grace means right there we
have a lot of different uh senses to it
we sometimes think of you know a dancer
as being graceful in their movement so
that's one sense but the older sense
grazia you know coming from Latin Harris
in in Greek is that of a Divine gift
that is given without any sort of
prediction or compelling it's just
gratuitously as coming from the word
Grace given to a person and that's what
happens in the story right so he says
um this is what produces for us the The
Joy This Joy
um
is going to come from this this glimpse
of something so he says a fairy tale
doesn't deny the existence of Deuce
catastrophe of sorrow and failure the
possibility of these is necessary to the
joy of Deliverance it denies Universal
final defeat and insofar as it is
evangelium evangelium is the word for in
Latin for gospel and what is evangelium
or gospel actually mean
good news
the that's literally what uh gospel and
evangelium uh evangelium is actually a
Latin word that is just transliterating
the the Greek word Good Tidings good
announcements right and it gives us as
he says a fleeting glimpse of joy not a
guaranteed joy every time that you read
the fairy tale you won't automatically
get that right it's not a mechanism it's
an opening to something greater so he
says that uh Joy beyond the walls of the
world poignant as grief and sometimes
mixed with it I know that for myself
speaking personally when I see a
successful resolution like that through
all the sorrow and pain and conflict and
sacrifices it sometimes brings me to
tears even in my happiness I know that
was the case for me at the very end of
The Lord of the Rings as a child trying
to communicate that to my mom I was so
upset at the good ending of the book
so he says that it's the mark of a good
fairy story or of the higher or complete
kind that however wild its events
there we go however fantastic or
terrible the adventures it can give to
the child or man that hears it when the
turn comes a catch of the breath a beat
and lifting of the heart near to or
indeed accompanied by Tears as Keen as
that given by any form of literary art
and having a peculiar quality what a
wonderful phenomenological description
of what goes on when we sense when we
grasp this turning right so
this is is quite important he says uh
also even modern fairy stories can
produce this effect sometimes it's not
easy to do
it depends on the whole story which is
the setting of The turn and yet reflects
a glory backwards a tale that in any
measure succeeds in this point has not
wholly failed whatever flaws it may
possess and whatever mixture or
confusion of purpose it even happens
that Andrew laying Andrew Lang is the
person that Tolkien is kind of beating
up in this essay owns fairy story Prince
prigio unsatisfactory in many ways as
that is and so
um you know he he says far more powerful
and poignant is the effect in a serious
tale of fairy in such stories when the
sudden turn comes we get a piercing
glimpse of joy and hearts desire that
for a moment passes outside the frame
runs indeed the very web of story and
lets a gleam come through so what he's
telling us about here is that within
certain Stories the effect of it is to
take us not just into the story but
outside of it to a certain extent
and that there's a emotional reaction
that occurs a rightful emotional
reaction now he writes an epilogue
interestingly he says this Joy which I
have selected as the mark of the true
fairy story or as the seal upon it
merits more consideration so he's going
to give us some very interesting more
consideration the first thing that I
think is really important here he talks
about sub creators he says probably
every writer making a secondary World a
fantasy every sub Creator wishes in some
measure to be a real maker or hopes that
he is drawing on reality hopes that the
peculiar quality of this secondary world
if not all the details are derived from
reality or are flowing into it
if he achieves a quality that can fairly
be described by the dictionary
definition inner consistency of reality
it is difficult to conceive how this can
be if the work does not in some way
partake of reality and we could say well
what about cynical creators you know for
example J.J Ballard writing a novel just
to you know get it out there and make
some money or something like that early
on well there's a sort of sadness that
goes with that isn't there oh I didn't
bring it off you know one can have this
negatively but sub creators do wish to
be real makers and their hopes as he
says draw upon reality now this is
something that he said earlier about
secondary worlds and sub-creation
drawing on the primary world you can't
get away from it entirely even with
nonsense things like uh you know Alice
in Wonderland so he goes on
and he says that
The Peculiar quality of the joy in
successful fantasy can thus be explained
as a sudden glimpse
of the underlying reality or truth the
underlying reality or truth to what to
the story no not just to the story to
the primary world that we inhabit and
which itself may not be as primary a
reality as we often take it to be when
we close it off so he goes on and he
says
this is not only a consolation for the
sorrow of this world which would be the
case if it was just Escapist right
consolation is important
but it's also a satisfaction
that's important as well
and it's also an answer to the question
is it true
the answer to this question that I gave
at first was quite rightly and he's
talking here about secondary creation if
you have built your little world well
yes it is true in that world in the
secondary world that's enough for the
artist or the artist part of the artist
but going Beyond this in the U
catastrophe we see in a brief Vision
that the answer may be greater the
answer to the question is it true yes it
is true in the secondary world yes it is
true in a different sense
true not in totality you could say
because it gives us a glimpse rather
than giving us an entirely coherent
secondary world
he says it may be a far-off gleam or
echo of now now notice what he says
evangelium in the real world so he
doesn't say it may be a far-off gleamer
echo of the real world it may be a
far-off gleam or echo of evangelium in
the real world and he says the use of
this word gives a hint of my epilogue
it's a serious and dangerous matter
uh it is incredibly important right that
he's going to bring up the Christian
story and it's entirely understandable
that Tolkien would bring this up you
know he is a practicing Roman Catholic
that plays a big role in his work but
he's not writing this from you could say
an exclusionary perspective where he's
saying oh only the Christian story is
good and only this version of it is good
as a matter of fact what he's saying
here could be extended to other uh
religious narratives as well I think and
so he's going to tell us that the
Christian story
is
um he would say I venture to say that
approaching the Christian story from
this direction it's long been my feeling
a joyous feeling that God redeemed the
corrupt making creatures men in a way
fitting to this aspect as to others of
their strange nature and then notice
what he says he doesn't say all of the
Bible he says the Gospels
evangelium right he doesn't say Paul's
letters and theology he sure as hell
doesn't say the Book of Revelations
right which would actually be kind of
antithetical to this so he says the
gospels contain a fairy story or a story
of a larger kind which Embraces all the
essence of fairy stories why they
contain many Marvels peculiarly artistic
beautiful and moving mythical and their
perfect self-contained significance and
among the Marvels is the greatest and
most complete conceivable you
catastrophe at least in tolkien's view
right so what is this going to be
he tells us uh the story has entered
history in the primary world this is the
desire and aspiration of sub-creation
and has been raised to the level of
creation not just being in the primary
world or making things in the primary
world like you know a chalkboard or
shooting a video or something like that
and not just sub creation creating your
own however difficult this may be
secondary world that can compel
secondary belief and provide this but
something greater right the creation of
the primary world and the primary World
in which all these narratives become
possible
so he highlights several aspects of this
he talks about birth the birth of Christ
as the EU catastrophe of man's history
if you actually read the gospel
narratives it's not like you know the uh
Away in a Manger you know little uh
crash and stuff like that this is a
harrowing story soon after the Christ
child is born and the Magi I come and
all that sort of stuff Herod tries to
kill him right the family has to flee as
refugees into Egypt it couldn't have
been fun uh bringing a baby to birth in
some uh animal crap infested manger
right we go out and on and on right when
you actually read these narratives
you know it's really quite different
than the
sanitized versions that we often get
presented with so birth and then he
talks about the resurrection is the U
catastrophe of the story of the
Incarnation and I would also say of the
sacrifice and death this Story begins
and ends in Joy he says it is has
preeminently the inner consistency of
reality
and so you know Tolkien takes this as
sort of paradigmatic of the EU
catastrophe but we might you know ask
ourselves
can other religious perspectives
Supply narratives that are similarly
offering us a glimpse into something
joyful something Beyond even this
primary world
then he goes on and he says something
really interesting and this is I think
he says he wants to say is applying to
the Christian narrative but it's it's a
broader scope it is not difficult to
imagine the peculiar excitement and joy
one would feel if any specially
beautiful fairy story were found to be
primarily true a story about the real
world its narrative to be history
without thereby necessarily losing the
mythical or allegorical significance it
had possessed so excitement and joy
would be resulting from this finding
something true he says the joy would
have exactly the same quality if not in
the same degree as the joy which the
turn in a fairy story gives such Joy has
the very Taste of primary truth
otherwise its name he says would not be
Joy
it looks forward or backward
to the great you catastrophe and he says
the Christian Joy the glory is of the
same kind but it is preeminently high
and joyous right
interestingly he says another thing too
about the Great and the small so he says
in God's kingdom the presence of the
greatest does not depress the small this
is part of what is distinctive about
God's kingdom and you might even say
this is an index by which we can judge
whether people who are talking about
God's kingdom are actually full of crap
or just trying to get over something on
us or are deluded or whether they're
actually in touch with it the great does
not negate the small as a matter of fact
it helps the small to be the small like
he says redeemed human being is still
human beings story fantasy still go on
and should go on the evangelium has not
abrogated Legends it has hallowed them
made them holy especially the happy
ending the Christian still has to work
with mind as well as body suffer hope
and die but he may now perceive that all
his Benson faculties have a purpose
which can be redeemed and this as he
says this is a bounty that he's been
treated to he may now fairly dare to
Guess that in fantasy he may actually
assist
in the exfoliation and multiple
enrichment of creation all Tales may
come true and yet at the last redeemed
they may be as like and unlike as the
forms we give them as man finally
redeemed will be like and unlike the
Fallen that we know so very
interestingly here once again buying
into the gospels believing in
Christianity practicing doesn't rule out
other stories as a matter of fact as
Tolkien says it Hallows them right and
we might think to bring this to a
conclusion about tolkien's own work as a
sub Creator not just in The Hobbit and
The Lord of the Rings but think about
the samarillon and the story of creation
that goes on there and all of the things
that happened in the first and second
age of Middle Earth or think about his
other works as well that stand on their
own like in a farmer Giles of ham and
leaf by niggle about the artist right
all of these are in tolkien's view
exemplifications of what he is
discussing here this EU catastrophe and
the evangelium and the joy that is
produced both in generating it
participating in sub-creation and in our
own engagement of it as readers